luego de que el consejo de seguridad de
la onu calificar al gobierno del
presidente de belarús alexander
lukashenko como una amenaza para la
estabilidad regional eeuu también se
mostró preocupado por la actual
situación en la frontera entre belarús y
polonia
sobre la cuestión de belarús y lo que
sucede en la frontera con polonia
estamos muy preocupados y le estamos
prestando mucha atención
el régimen de lukashenko está
involucrado en una actividad muy
preocupante
chaplin acceder y
preocupaciones también expresadas por la
otan que se dijo vigilante ante la
posibilidad de una escalada en la línea
fronteriza
por su parte belarús dijo que el
ejército respondería con dureza a
cualquier ataque en medio de la actual
crisis migratoria cientos de migrantes
siguen llegando a la frontera con la
esperanza de cruzar a territorio europeo
el lenguaje de ultimátum a amenazas y
chantajes es inaceptable las fuerzas
armadas de la república de belarús están
listas para responder con dureza ante el
ataque el jueves el mandatario
bielorruso amenazó con bloquear el
suministro de gas que llegue a europa a
través de su país sin embargo el kremlin
se comprometió a garantizar el
suministro de combustible rusia ha
demostrado su apoyo a su aliado
bielorruso tras los señalamientos
europeos que acusan a lukashenko de
fomentar la crisis migratoria a manera
de retaliación por las sanciones
impuestas a su gobierno mientras tanto
la situación en la frontera se sigue
agravando decenas continúan varados
entre ellos muchos menores de edad cuyos
padres piden con carteles ayuda a la
comunidad internacional